the creepypasta horror meme Slenderman
has slowly risen in stature over the
last decade after starring in fan
fiction documentaries games and more the
monster finally debuts on the silver
screen in the film Slender Man
throughout this video I will be
discussing the movie's plot as well as
what I took from the ending of the film
and what the monster means there will be
heavy spoilers so it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you want
to go into Slender Man unspoiled with
that out the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to the
film centers around for friends dealing
with the consequences of summoning the
Slender Man after one of the four katie
goes missing the other three discover
that the girl had been fascinated with
the mysterious monster and decide to
attempt to make contact with it in hopes
of getting her back one of the girls ren
warns the to not to open their eyes when
making contact with the Slender Man as
seeing it will result in death or
madness however during the summoning
Chloe panics and opens her eyes thus
viewing the monster this causes the
Slender Man to take her to where we
never find out but one could assume it
is the doctor I mention that the Slender
Man comes from and uses to teleport with
the surviving girls are haunted and
stalked by the Slender Man and after
Holly's sister and Ren attempts to
recontact it they get put into further
danger Holly realizes that the Slender
Man wants to take her sister after she
goes into a panic attack
and must be hospitalized Holly desperate
to save her sister from the clutches of
the Slender Man officer betrayed of
herself commit simply
place the Slenderman accepts this deal
and takes Halle instead of her sister in
the final scene we see that Halle sister
is able to leave the hospital and
reflects on the situation that resulted
in the death of her sister and her
friends the symbolism of this ties
directly into the real-life Slenderman
attack that happened in 2014 this
involved two girls attempting to murder
their friend hoping to appease the
Slenderman both girls were sentenced to
an institution and diagnosed with severe
mental illness other similarities to the
real-life case are that Kate you
researched the character much in the
same way that the two attackers did and
Halle sister had to deal with the
consequences of what happens when trying
to appease the Slenderman similar to
those two girls personally I would have
liked a bit more ambiguity around the
monster in the movies so that we could
have drawn the conclusion that one of
the girls was causing the disappearances
this would have tied into the real-life
events that happened and also allow the
audience to struggle over the fact that
the girls may have imagined the events
due to their psychosis and the
willingness to believe in the entity
much in the same way that people
convince themselves of other paranormal
happenings my personal view on the film
is that the Slenderman doesn't actually
exist and he is only a figment of their
imaginations the girls are the only
characters that are able to see the
Slenderman and even when one is being
strangled by the entity we can see that
there is actually nothing there and the
attack is self-inflicted throughout the
film several of the characters are
missing their eyes and to me this
symbolizes that the characters are
blinded of mental illness within the
girls as it does not manifest on the
surface Holly's sister has a panic
attack which could be brought on by
extreme anxiety and the dark dimension
that Slenderman comes from could
symbolize the dark parts of our mind
that cause depression the line once you
see him you can't unsee him also has
further implications to me this implies
that there is no cure for Slenderman
much in the same way that there is no
real cure for men
illness and the further the girls fall
into their own minds the more they push
each other apart this is a really
interesting aspect of the film but sadly
it decides not to go fully down this
route and is a rather surface-level
horror film filled with jump scares and
underdeveloped characters to me this is
a missed opportunity as it could have
explored mental illness bullying and
other elements that are often overlooked
in mainstream media this is a shame as
there's a lot of Slenderman material I
enjoy such as the games and fan fiction
and if properly utilized there is a lot
you can do with the creature so what did
you think of the Slender Man movie would
you have preferred it to be a study on
the stabbing or do you think it's better
as a work of pure fiction comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and subscribe
to my channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the origins of the Slender Man
so make sure you check that video out
linked at the end of this one thanks
very much for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]